has there been like a fire what's going
on there's elk outside
how many elk four sorry we're gonna take
a break to go look at some elk
[Music]
oh hello and welcome to she doesn't read
the news with me chris turner and
myself alice win my wife hey wife hello
hey can i tell everyone about the
exciting thing that happened today
yes oh my gosh now we do not fully know
what this beast was we're not 100 sure
but go on i i
the way no just tell so i i had one of
those moments where you know people
always talk about witnesses and how
witnesses are really unreliable
eyewitness testimony it fades even a few
seconds after and you can't tell whether
there were three men or five men or the
number of gunshots people don't know i'd
received a text from david buckingham
who is an artist
friend of ours and it said be mine you
lie me so i was taking a photo to send
back to him
including one of his artworks that is in
his house and
out the corner of my eye i saw a scuffle
on the windowsill
outside now when i'd come down there'd
been a little bunny
curled up against the windowsill because
we live in the outdoors
and quite frequently there is a bunny
gaining warmth from the
the window i thought that i saw
a tiny cat outside pounce at the rabbit
fall on the floor and then both run away
and i thought well that can't be
possible because it looked exactly the
same size as our kitten
gorbachev who is here in the house and
so i thought but i did see it outside
no it must not be gorbachev and so i
doubted myself for about half an hour
and then i saw our big cat colonel
widowshins the king
looking out the window at this just
creature it was like if you combined a
cat with a tiny bear
like a weasley ferret creature but we
did end up iding it and did it and i'll
tell you how
it's because my great-aunt sis when she
died
left me a mink stole that is truly
horrible
it's five whole minks like mouth to us
and a mink is like it's like a human
centipede of minks it is it absolutely
is and they've got their tiny little
clawed paws uh just dangling
it's a horrible garment i wear it as
often as i can if you're only listening
on the podcast this is a reason to watch
on my youtube because i just did i think
a very good impression of
the mixed faces i'll do it again in case
you missed it watching
well be that as it may uh
we had only to consider the mink stole
to look at the mink i think it must have
been a mink
i know it's not a mink it wasn't a mink
your mother posted a video of it and it
was identified
no it's a mink no it's not a me what is
it minks apparently have webbed
toes and live near water what is that
creature if it's not
they're very much like frogs in that
regard yes uh it's a pine martin
no it isn't it's a pine water it's a
pine martin
my dad used to have a friend called
martin when he got divorced he was a
pining mountain
i saw this fluffy beast with a big
feathery tail and he hung around outside
the window and hopped around in the snow
gambling frolicking he was very sweet it
was beautiful
so that was a great start to my day and
it's been downhill since then not
because it's been an unpleasant day just
because
how can a day get better than a new
fluffy creature you've never seen before
right outside your house
well it is valentine's day it's
valentine's day so it can get better
we'll have a nice
romantic dinner romantic with my would
you
eat pizza with my parents valentine's
day that's nice to commemorate the the
day where all couples celebrate the
valentine's day okay
we have a friend valentine's day
massacre yeah it's
al capone killed loads of people in a
restaurant on valentine's day well
that's very
grim and i didn't know that um with a
friend who has a theory that valentine's
day
is really more about single people than
um
couples and i do think that that's right
it's very valid because you know couples
whatever single people you know it's
that thing of like oh should i send a
valentine's day card to that person who
i
smile at in starbucks yay or nay you
know it's much more
um relevant i think how many valentine's
day cards did you get at school
i don't think i have an
answer for that was that not a thing so
at my primary school
we used to have a little post box that
you put valentine's day cards in there
be distributed amongst the class
they were never cross-class distributed
because you know when you're five years
old
why would you ever give a letter to a
six-year-old they're far too old for you
that's of course
that's 20 there's a 20 difference that's
that's mad that's like me dating a 37
year old doesn't feel that bad
um did you never get them
how is 37 a 37 year old is not 20
older than you yeah it is if i'm 31 10
is three years point one and then double
that
six years so six years would be you know
oh god math is just
boggling isn't it i have received some
valentine's day cards
um from you know paramours
hayley williams sent you a valentine's
day card
but uh no nothing nothing of interest
really she keeps advertising
mental health counselling to me on
facebook does she yeah
does she think you're in trouble i don't
know i think they just target it at
men in their 30s and think yeah they're
probably having a crisis and they would
be correct
they would be correct um i'm excited to
watch a valentine's day movie with your
parents tonight
i'm also excited to share my favorite
your parents story of the week which i
think we can share okay which was that
we had
a lunar new year feast which was lovely
and at the end of it your dad complained
of having
a pain in his foot this was and he was
like what painkillers should i take and
we're like
why he said because my foot hurts and
everyone suddenly is very sympathetic
it felt more sympathetic than i think a
foot pain deserves
it's because my father is is very aged
no that's not he yes it is if an eight
is wise if an aged person comes to you
with a pain like
you you know that's concerning if you
come to me with a pain i'm like get over
it yeah whereas if you were in your
late 60s then you're like oh you've
understood a lifetime of pain and so for
you to bring this up this must be
painful
i do think it was a painful pain when we
went to the bottom of it
the older people their taste buds decay
so in the same way that their taste
weakens
their actual understanding of pain their
palate
of pain grows yeah okay fine so
he came to us and was like which
medicine should i take
paracetamol or ibuprofen although he
calls it tylenol
and advil because in america it's all
different names
and i was just sat there feeling like
everyone was being
quite overreacting on this your brother
was like
it's bone spurs it must be bone spurs
and he goes yeah maybe it's bone spurs
and then he describes when it happened
he was just sat
reading a book and suddenly his heel
starts hurting by the way it doesn't
sound like how
bolsters spurs work it's not like you
don't have bone spurs story makes me
so uncomfortable because when we find
out what the pain is i just it makes me
cringe
so finally he comes back out several
it wasn't happening anyway he comes out
and he goes i figured out what the pain
is
and we're like what was the pain and
he's like i had a
needle in my foot a whole needle
he hadn't taken off his slippers right
he got this pain in his foot and his
first port of cool was not
take off my shoot i should look at the
wound it was like no
i should check with the entire family to
see what painkiller i should take but
he checked hours after the situation
because he reads his books at two
o'clock three o'clock in the afternoon
this was
the feast which was about nine o'clock
so he'd gone through the day
going oh this this feels like i've got a
sharp pain in my foot
well i won't look to see if that's a
sharp thing in my foot by needle i'll
clarify we don't mean a hypodermic
needle a syringe
we mean a sewing needle yeah which is
big
it's still big it makes and also a
hypodermic needle is designed to go in
your skin
actually oh god we'll stop talking about
cringe it was
it was my highlight of the week before i
saw that martin imagine if that pine
martin had a needle in its foot it would
have been amazing no it wouldn't it
wouldn't look awful
you walk around with five dead minks on
your neck alice
actually clarification doesn't walk
around with them i i sashay
yeah i show up at comedy gigs now this
is like hold my
furs darling her is and always will be
murder
maybe if they got a scottish person to
do the adverts
people would listen to it more my
favorite thing about the fur adverts are
it's always
celebrities getting naked going you
wouldn't wear my skin
you're like yeah you would probably fit
maybe i would wear that skin
they need to get some like horror like
alex jones going it wouldn't wear my
skin and you know who's alex jones he's
the the right wing conspiracy theorist
nut from infowars
one couple that everyone's been talking
about this week uh and we enjoyed
tremendously and let us add our
recommendation
the britney spears documentary the
britney spears
it's a good watch it's on hulu it's also
available
illegally not that we recommend that but
whoa
whoa whoa whoa free britney i'm behind
the cause yeah no it was persuasive
uh it made me feel bad because i
remember
in 2008 being like lol brittany's so
crazy
uh you're not shining a connor where's
your hair gone no
yeah we were we were complicit sinead
o'connor actually also someone who was
kind of
i don't know who that is blacklisted
she's the irish singer of nothing
compares to you
and on a performance on saturday night
live she tore up a photo of the pope
in reference to the catholic sexual
abuse scandals and this is long before
that broke and so everyone was like
whoa schneider connor you're wild you
can't be on this show anymore you tore a
picture of the pope
and obviously she had a point
um women who were wronged in the past
those are the only two though that was
luckily it was the just down to the
stake were witches and you can't
where's the evidence that they weren't
they're dead they're dead
um okay yes it was a good documentary
uh it made us feel it made us
sort of reconsider our actions in the
past i saw a buzzfeed article that was
like
it was like um diane sawyer owes britney
an apology and all the comments were
like
diane sawyer was interviewing britney
saying oh
so people want to kill you it was an
outrageous interview yeah it was
but anyway the point is all these
comments from people being like diane
sawyer
like you need to apologize to brittany
now why haven't she why hasn't she done
it yet
and i i my mother was like well she's
dead she died in a horrible way
her car rolled backwards down a hill
into a pool of mud and
sank yeah she drowned in mud he spears
just in justin timberlake apologized for
his behavior because he did
act like a bit of a [ __ ] he did act
like a [ __ ] i
do also feel as if uh i think it's
better to try and
learn from one's mistakes and move on
than to retroactively
blame people for things that were
natural at the time
right you know he was just trying to
sell records as well like it makes you
know
think about jay-z and beyonce they had
back-to-back number one hits with 99
problems
and crazy in love which were so
successful because
like beyonce is saying i'm crazy in love
i've got a boyfriend and i was like is
it jay-z
and then jay-z goes i got nothing no
problems but a [ __ ] ain't won
there's no one that won't evolve they
both went to number one and it fed off
the craze of it and so
justin timberlake did release an
incredible song it is a good song it's a
great song
that was so accurate that we are going
to get copyright strikes on youtube for
using justin timberlake's primary river
but
uh yeah i don't know it's not i'm not
saying you know i condone this baby i
just i just think it's uh
i have i feel troubled when we try and
impose the morality of the present on
the past alice believes there is a
moratorium
i do feel as if uh basically there's a
swivel
a moral swivel around 2013. i think if
you wore
a native american headdress to coachella
in 2011 as a white girl
you could just be clueless but if you
wore that same native american headdress
to coachella in 2014
you're probably being a bit of a dick
news story i wasn't going to touch on
but there was a contestant kicked off
the bachelor or bachelorette
because of the antebellum party she
attended in 2012 2018 which is too
recent
that's too recent it is pretty recent
yeah
yeah um the host of the bachelor has
quit because he defended her
well i i think um you know i i don't
know
i i think it's interesting because you
know because of the lost cause movement
you know about the lost course of my
thing
um very vaguely but do do it elucidate
so
um some people think that to a degree
although the south lost
the civil war they kind of won the peace
um partly because the in the
reconstruction there was a little more
focus
on helping white southerners get on
their feet and helping freed slaves get
on their feet
uh and essentially white southerners
were kind of able to to
re-capture the narrative
and this became the lost cause movement
the lost cause
was the gracious and noble cause
of the chevalric south that had been
defeated whilst fighting very
valiantly for states rights against the
uh
you know increasingly secular
industrialized modernist
north and it's the group called the
daughters of the confederacy they're the
people that
i don't know how they fit in i mean they
definitely are part of they're the ones
that
tried to perpetuate it by putting up all
these statues and then when there was
the debate about should we pull down
statues people saying they're part of
our heritage and then there was that
graph that
showed like so many of them were up in
the mid 1900s these
these things it's 1960 let's put up a
confederate soldier statue sure
so so the thing is the lost course
movement isn't like you know it's not
like a
club with a list of names on it it's
more of a
a club called the lost cause would have
some crazy nights
everyone there like um dj who gives a
[ __ ] welcome to the last cars
[Music]
so so famous um famous instances of the
lost cause movement so one of the things
that oscars movement did
everything i just said they came to the
south as chevalric and
um you know robbie lee and uh stonewall
jackson became these kind of like
knightly figures um fighting against
these you know more
more um it's really about industry right
uh industry versus the romantic
past oh okay the the smoky satanic mills
coming down to the
oh lovely cottage yes exactly look at
these beautiful pastoral rolling hills
with
humans being enslaved absolutely and
so uh two classic instances of the lost
course movement
are the birth of a nation the film from
1915.
exactly and uh and the birth of the
nation by the way so
so for those of you who haven't watched
i haven't watched it but this is what
it's about it's about um the ku klux
klan but it paints the ku klux klan as
being
these like noble um saviors of white
southern um femininity essentially and
it's awkward because
as far as i know in film history d.w
griffiths is as far as i'm aware in the
canon of films
an inventor of so many different types
of shots like that film itself
uses so many innovative techniques that
no one had ever used before and so if
you want to see where these came from
you have to watch a film that is
by moral standards and even past
standards morally republican
yes and and a similar thing is true of
gone with the wind which is the other
great lost caused film and
uh lost so go with the wind is um you
know it's a
really good film and that's part of the
problem and i i saw tana hassey coat
speak once
and he talked about gone with the wind
and he was like i won't watch it to this
day because i think it's still it
continues
to cause problems and he's like i'm not
saying it shouldn't be watched i'm not
saying it should be thrown out of the
cannon i'm just saying
i will i cannot watch that film thrown
out of the cannon as in cannon with a
single n in the middle
the filmic cannon not a hunter s
thompson-esque we should burn it and
shoot his ashes out of it
hunter s thompson had his ashes shot out
he's very extra i think when you have
that life you're like how can i top it i
wrote fear and loathing in las vegas
which is not that good a book let's be
honest
i read it when i was a teenager i
thought it was brilliant because it's
drugs you know what they you know
where you get the book club where they
read that the lost cause mate let's go
down to the nightclub
listen to some dead mouse i would prefer
it if you didn't
espouse them lost cause uh but anyway
the nightclub
not the movement of the south this
nightclub would be northerners only
let's start a new
dividing line civil war that's what we
want what i'm getting at with
this antebellum party that this woman
attended in 2018
is that the lost cause movement was so
successful
that um it really effectively
in the mainstream media rehabilitated
slave owners
and that's how you can have people
having plantation weddings like
not that long people are still there
this june with the black lives matter
movement in the wake of the death of
brianna taylor and george floyd the
bands such as lady antebellum and the
dixie chicks
renamed they became lady a and the
chicks
then this wasn't in 2018 they did this
was now right
yeah and i think it's it's just um
you know the the this it's maybe facile
to make um
nazi comparisons but i'm gonna do it
anyway uh
just be careful because they did kick
that woman off the mandalorian
because she said that having differing
political opinions what she meant was
right-wing political opinions
was like being a jew in nazi germany and
the rule of thumb i think and i think
it's a really simple rule of thumb
unless you are talking about the jews in
nazi germany don't
make comparisons to the jews in nazi
germany i do think that's probably we
were shepherded
into concentration camps in our millions
and slaughtered it's just like being the
jews in nazi germany
i think that's a fair comparison
probably all other ones
just be better at similes like why
why are you going to one of the most
just come on be
more independent there's an internet
rule isn't there the moment you bring up
hitler you've lost
the argument yes unless the argument is
who was the leader of germany
in the 1930s okay but hit me up so what
i'm saying
is uh that you know after germany lost
world war
ii uh you know there weren't statues of
hitler put
up in germany and let's be honest the
nazis were glamorous they had their
uniforms designed by hugo boss
style and only recently did hugo boss
the company apologize for that
really yeah i think it's because they
were like i mean they were pretty good
uniforms
so what i'm trying to get out here is
that uh
the antebellum south is not the only
time that a group that has been doing
something particularly evil has also had
style
it's just that it's been surprising how
long it's been allowed
yeah to to be considered
styling confederate flags were only just
banned at nascar races
mississippi i think a few months ago
stopped issuing confederate
flag license plates like
it's until now it it's surprising
especially because i mean the
confederates
were considered you know at the time
like you know
traitors because they were just trying
to succeed from the nation i mean robert
e lee himself
was against seceding from the union he
was like this is a crazy thing to do i
think it's unpatriotic i think it's
going against what the founding fathers
believed in
i just think that the um the
rehabilitation process
has just been very very uh
complicated and twisting and has had a
very lasting impact on
current american thinking you know as
tanahasi coates points out it's not
it's not just a case of like oh this is
a film
that has bad you know has politics i
don't agree with it's a case of this is
a film that has politics i don't agree
with
that continue to form politics of people
i disagree with
now do you see what i mean it's
different from
it's it's different from uh i don't know
like a film from the 50s it's a bit
rapey so about the week's news the main
story of the week what was the main
story of the week you asked me this
morning
has any this is how alice knows
something's happened because someone
messaged her and said hey you okay are
you doing all right are you holding up
and i was like has there been like a
fire what's going on there's elk outside
how many elk four sorry we're going to
take a break to go look at some elk
apologies for that unscheduled break for
us to go and gorp at some
horned beasts they're majestic there's
like 14 or 15 of them
[ __ ] off big elk um i i pre
you you didn't notice but i pressed my
nose up against
the window and they have like these
little grills over the window like a fly
screen
and i i it's not really nice and musty
so i started inhaling and then realized
it's just all the dead moths and
detritus that gather at the bottom of
the windows so that was
i've inhaled a fair few dead flying
beasties
um that's the the dangers of recording
in a beautiful isolated
colorado wilderness uh we can see out
the windows and i'll get distracted by
elk and i will continue to refer to them
because they're just hanging out there
right in my eye line biggest news this
week alice found out about this news
because a friend of hers
just said hey i hope you're okay and i
was like yeah what's
chris what's going on he was like i'll
tell you later i came out the shower and
she
she says she says something happened and
he said
he said i'll tell you later and i was
like no wait i didn't like because
someone's asked me who i am and he was
like well
the impeachment yeah if you wonder why
we are so excited to talk to each other
it's because i refuse to talk
since starting the podcast i refuse to
talk to her all week i only do it
in this time period so yeah the
impeachment
of donald trump donald john trump never
knew his name was john
that's what they kept calling they don't
call him president trump now they call
him former president donald johnson that
reminds me of how
when um murray antoinette was being
brought to be executed they didn't call
her mary antoinette or
you know her majesty they called her
widow cafe
oh that's the
i guess the family name of makes sense
yeah yeah
i wrong family names like uh archie
the daughter of the daughter the son of
megan and harry is mountbatten windsor
it's a great name it's also ridiculous i
love it i think i'm very into it
okay so he's bending i'm sorry i'm
trying not to be stupid here but he has
already been impeached he has been
impeached and he's also a year ago he's
also
now no longer president so how is he
being impeached so that was a big thing
a lot of the republicans said this is an
unconstitutional trial because
you can't impeach someone who's no
longer president impeachment is removed
from office and the democrats
said well you can impeach and we're just
we you know we're impeaching him for
something he did when he was president
just because
you leave the country doesn't mean you
haven't you know the crime you committed
so and pete to impeach someone is to
remove someone from the
no to impeach someone is to vote in the
house
that they have done something wrong he
has been impeached he hasn't been
removed from office he hasn't been
convicted
in the senate it's very puzzling and
confusing but he's been impeached first
president to be impeached twice
which is you know a lofty aim but yeah
well done make it three don get back in
just so you can make it three
uh okay so so when do we find out
whether he's gonna well
he hasn't he hasn't that they did it
very quickly which again a lot of
republicans were very upset by saying
hey last time they had 33 days to
prepare this time it was just like boom
boom boom boom boom boom wouldn't the
republicans be glad because he got off
uh yes but i think the republicans were
looking for arguments to
just to explain why they were going to
vote against it because only seven
republicans voted to
convict which is six more than did last
time because romney was the only one
last time
this time it was it was seven he was
nice to me once in a restaurant
well that's nice it shows that
politicians although they can be nice
are still evil people um he's less bad
than the others i thought mitt romney uh
i think
now i thought now he's kind of fairly on
board with it
like oh this man who used to beat me
when i was a child has now been like hey
we shouldn't beat children
he still beat you when you were a child
mitt romney has never beaten anyone as a
child as far as
i don't know if that seems like a
perfectly accurate comparison
uh yeah okay i guess him being nice to
you in a restaurant
okay hey he was nice to me in a
restaurant and b hasn't he been one of
the only republicans to kind of stand up
against trump for most of
yes but because it doesn't matter
because when you're one person you can
do it in the same way all the
republicans voting against him
have either just been elected to the
senate so have six years until they're
up to vote again or
are retiring i still think it shows
courage
and i'm not saying it does because the
gop all the individual parties the south
carolina party the louisiana party the
georgia
parties have then censured the members
who have voted
to impeach donald trump they've all said
this is why have you done that that's
mad there's no way he was guilty
when the ones who voted said no he's
clearly guilty of inciting a riot
um and the republicans who say the
republicans voting against it either say
this is unconstitutional so we shouldn't
have this trial so we're voting against
it
this is a witch hunt or they were gonna
write anyway
which is a stupid argument because the
riot was as a result of rhetoric that
started with trump and the republican
party
so if you think it's unconstitutional i
think that's a fair reason to vote
against it
if you think you cannot impeach someone
who's not in office
then yeah fine vote against it but it
feels weird when they're like no they
would have done this anyway
it's you know because the evidence that
came out and the democrats wanted
witnesses
um and then the democratic leadership
said no we're not going to call
witnesses because it'll drag the trial
up for three months and essentially they
didn't want it to become a show trial to
overshadow biden's
presidency right they just want to focus
on that which
i don't know i think having witnesses in
there would have
you know dragged on and people would
have been like oh yeah this this guy
was a real piece of [ __ ] so say he had
been successfully indicted
convicted convicted what would have
happened um they could have then passed
a motion that would have stopped him
running for public office
any kind of public office yeah do you
think it's likely that he i mean i know
he says he is going to
i don't think he will i think someone
said on twitter
that he's gonna spend the next two years
getting his revenge
on the republicans who voted to convict
him
and republicans like mitch mcconnell
gave a real
fiery speech saying this is trump's
fault i don't think it's constitutional
so i'm not gonna vote for it but it's
trump's fault
wait i thought mitch mcconnell and trump
were best friends since december
but they were they were like primary
school best friends they were best best
friends for three years and then they
entered okay see that one
see that feels a lot more sneaky because
it's like
he he stayed in trump's pocket until the
very last minute and then jumped ship
right that yeah that doesn't what mitch
mcconnell
a sneaky conniving prick what a surprise
he wasn't nice to you in a restaurant
wasn't it but he did go to my brother's
christening
what what a revelation you heard it here
first folks
in the pocket of mitch i'm not
republican
your middle name is mitch mcconnell no
um
anyway alice mitch mcconnell um
we're not friends with him the the
evidence that came out
was that uh
trump had called kevin mccarthy the
house republican leader
and mccarthy's like mccarthy called him
was like hey
your supporters are invading the capital
and trump said well they must care more
about the election than you do kevin
[Laughter]
so that was pretty good they wanted to
have witnesses to call about that and in
the end they
made a deal the thing is though right if
you did believe
like these people did that the election
had been stolen from you
then oh yeah you have no choice yeah as
an american but just
you are protecting democracy so you know
i i don't know if this is a very foolish
or unpopular opinion but i i can't help
but feel that you know they're
sort of the victims of whatever it is
that they've been uh
exposed to in terms of information i
know it's easy to be like well yeah if
you like the president and you believe
in him
and then he says this has happened then
you trust him and yeah
they were lied too fast you know
questionable to like that president but
there you go i i just
i think it's um it's a curious time to
be alive
yeah um next week our special guest will
be mitch mcconnell we have his phone
number he's going to come on the podcast
one of the highlights of the trump trial
was on the first day
his lawyer was one of the shittiest so
no one will represent him because a he
doesn't pay his lawyers and b
they don't want to be tarnished i'm
sorry how is he being like it's good
exposure like what is he offering
it's like yeah yeah to come and do my
gig it would be helpful for your career
no so one of his his main lawyer he
pulled off
oh that sounds really didn't do that um
he's not a fan of that he
he took him off the case or the lead of
the case after the first day because he
gave this
rambling monologue during which he like
argued for why the trial should be
happening
accepting that the democrats had made
some very good points in their opening
arguments
and one of the republican senators who
voted to convict trump
said oh after that that was so bad i'm
voting to convict
and then like it's an own goal he was
like well you know it was the
opening argument that's why i'm voting
to convict trump because that was really
bad
wow how do you swing someone yeah that
that's not a great lawyer so he got he
got taken off and they switched it to
another lawyer who um
the funniest bit of the trial was when
he said if we have witnesses i will have
their depositions in my office
in philadelphia and every everyone in
this in the chamber started laughing
and he thought they were laughing at the
idea of depositions
and he went i don't know how many
lawyers we have here that's how it works
and everyone keeps laughing he goes
what's so funny nothing's funny and like
he had an argument with bernie sanders
that reminds me of an improv when you
you're making a joke
and you think everyone's laughing at
your joke but actually one of your
[ __ ] improvisers is behind you doing
something hilarious and you're like
everyone loves my joke and they don't
they just love
the person behind it's like that time i
did a whole stand-up set with one
testicle hanging out my flies
i am killing tonight absolutely and
that's why it's become a staple of my
act ever since if you come to my live
shows you will see
so uh from from one funny lawyer to a
second funny lawyer
i think the best video on the internet
since the uh bbc interview with the man
being introduced kids happened this
weekend you're an absolute
it doesn't sound as good as it is no
when your mother walked over to the
table going have you seen this
and my automatic response to that with
all respect to your mother is
this is probably an internet thing that
i have seen before it's
just a man a lawyer on a zoom call for
work
who accidentally has left a cat filter
on
and let me say this was so funny that if
you watch this video which you
definitely should
it's three people on a zoom call and in
the top left corner it's a space in the
zoom call
because this is from a judicial hearing
these are you are not allowed in courts
just the same way you're not allowed to
broadcast what goes on
and it says unauthorized recording or
distribution
of this meeting is punishable by five
years in prison and a 20 000
fine or whatever number it is and the
judge
from this case said i am releasing this
footage because it is so perfect
this is incredible and it really is it
really brought me joy
it's and when we say it's a cat filter
it's not even
it's not like a snapchat thing where you
can see his body
it's a white screen with a cat's face
with it so it's just a
a talking cat being like in this deep
southern accent guys move with his eyes
and his mouth matches his mouth
it's so good i think we can't describe
it anymore i mean we have to just
the highlight of it is when the judge
explains like i think you have a filter
on
and the guy says um i'm not a cat
um i'm here judge i'm not a cat
and the judge goes i can see that
it's funnier because he's suddenly
because he's so flustered with like
i have i have violated all protocols
he's behaving he's trying to be so
polite and welcoming and nice
yeah it is it is a marvelous
gift to the internet watch it the thing
is the internet is so often
a force for evil and then occasionally
these sort of bright lights gleam
through the cracks and you think is it
all worth it
yeah i think it was worth the trolling
and the you know
misleading in the brexit vote and in the
u.s election to get this
cat and afterwards there was a follow-up
article with him and it said
lawyer shocked to become meme due to any
like
you're an idiot you don't know how the
internet works you did a funny thing on
zoom
as a cat instant meme
instant meme covered news always some
covert news but there's two stories this
week
in massachusetts they said
just to make things simpler with a
vaccine if you're taking in someone in
one of these vulnerable groups and they
need a caregiver
we'll vaccinate the caregiver at the
same time and so in massachusetts there
has been a mad
scramble for people to find elderly
infirm disabled people
and be like hey can i give you a lift to
the covered vaccination clinic
yes get in they're all being like that
um you know
in the best movie of all time apart from
gladiator titanic uh billy zane's
character
when the lifeboats are starting to be
like only women and children he just
grabs a spare
weeping child and goes up to the
lifeboat and goes please
i'm all he has
what a great film you know we should
really watch that tonight that's never
happening
why not it's the longest film in the
world it's the best
it's like it starts with 45 minutes of
an old woman looking at it
that she eventually dropped a james
horner soundtrack
it is oh so it's like every other james
horner soundtrack amusing on the
hubris of empire kate winslow getting
naked leonardo capra is actually
looking for a second i'm watching that
movie and those
boobies gross i know are they i don't
watch it then no
all i know about titanic is you have
seen it
screen screen that was me miming my hand
going down a car window i have seen it
yes so you should see it again
i should see oh no dear oh dear no
that's happening in massachusetts people
are jumping the queue by helping out
others it's kind of like you know
if that means that some people who need
the vaccine get the vaccine and some
people don't go back together vaccine it
is it's a wash
right and maybe maybe they'll make a
lifelong friendship maybe they'll fall
in love with the person they're taking
to the harold
yeah i mean i don't know i could imagine
i think you know chronic loneliness of
the elderly is a big problem
subject of harold and moored make sure
you watch my my video about how much i
love the older ladies
it's my mum's favorite video in quite a
while because it didn't include any rude
words
although she said she wouldn't show it
to my grandmother which i think is
antithetical to the point am i using the
word antithetical correctly i don't know
if you're using it syntactically
correctly ah
thank you am i are you using the word
syntactically correctly correct suddenly
not
i don't know what it means either second
covered news is
schools in san francisco are still
closed even though they've been
permitted to open since september
because teachers have said hi
we'd love to go back to teaching we'd
love the vaccine first though because
children
are walking vaccine hives walking virus
hives yeah yeah yeah
walking yeah yeah walking by our times
um
i think it's tricky with t so i teach uh
but i home school
and um so i you know it's been pretty
easy for me i've just been like i'm
doing it remotely
fine uh i think teachers are being put
in a really difficult position because
uh homeschooling one on one on zoom is
fine homeschooling
30 kids is not fine
and so the teachers want to get back but
also
that you know it is it's really a lot to
ask of someone
so i was speaking someone about this
this week and
every year of education that you miss
or every year of education this is the
study a year of education
across a child's life is worth an extra
forty thousand pounds
i think that's that's not a statistic
that's going to be able to apply me
to this but it just shows that like how
effective
education is at improving your ability
to earn and therefore presumably many
other things right sure
and so there is already huge damage
and i'll get on to the the actual damage
the stories about but
just the damage of learning from home
for a year it's nowhere near as good
you know everyone's saying this and i'm
not saying that that that that that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that that that that that's happening
socializing as well attention is it's
not the same time as an amount of
schools
i'm not saying that that that there
aren't defects i just i know if i was a
agenzia right now i think i would start
i would be starting
to get really fed up of everyone telling
me like oh
you know what's happening to you right
now is going to destroy you for the rest
of your life it's going to be giving
them strengths that we don't understand
yet
i think that's fair also i guess it is
mainly a level playing field for
because you know i would assume only
five percent of people are getting
the extra tutoring you know they've all
been disruptive you know it relies a lot
on parents being able to have the luxury
of being
able to have time to teach because you
know so many people are still working
their jobs while teaching their kids at
home and how does that even
work like there's not enough time in my
day and i have neither kids nor a real
job like so the the story is
san francisco the city the council is
suing
the school board for not opening because
of the damage done to kids mental health
and they have said
that they are seeing an increase an
increase in the rise of admissions to
emergency rooms with children who tried
to commit suicide and children who are
caused to lines about mental health
people saying that they're really
struggling
parents were saying that they saw their
their child at 11 in the morning
in the fetal position next to the laptop
just screaming um
people like smashing their heads into
the walls and children
yeah it's crazy and like what a horrible
position to be in because
you don't become a teacher if you don't
care about children's welfare
unless you are some of the teachers in
my secondary school who became teachers
because they
bloody hated children i also had my math
teacher in paris who was called madame
dubersk
and she hated children ugh i hate her
mainly because she's french but also
because she hated children
no i sort of actually grudgingly admire
her and her profound dislike of us
there are teachers who at the time i
thought were
bonkers and then came to love such as
miss sergeant who
when in a class in our like first first
year of school so i was like 12 maybe 11
12
and a secondary school i didn't go to
school for the first time when i was 12.
not some absolute prodigy i spent the
first 10 years of my life rapping guys
didn't have time for standard education
um she was asking everyone what do you
think in the book and everyone's like
good good good she went don't be sheep
and i i always thought i was very good
at doing sheep noises
sorry yeah right she must have like and
she
and she went turner two sides of a4 or
legal pad
sized paper um two sides of a4 the word
bar
until it's full
that's great i mean that's great that's
so ah madame dubask
used to she had this catchphrase which
was
me
thank you darling which means but it's
extra
like nothing like you know and she'd be
saying it about a person right she'd be
like you're
extra nothing it was um
pretty harrowing so yes uh i
i that's a really horrid situation i
really feel for the teachers in that
situation i feel for the kids as well i
i any time everyone turns on teachers
i'm always a bit like you know they get
paid
nothing yeah it's not great pr you know
what we'll do so
the teachers right they get paid
literally nothing
to do a job that is so so tough i can't
even imagine how tiring it would be to
work in school
uh because i i i work one-on-one and i
you know have hours off
and uh it's a completely different ball
game
it's like a performance yeah you know it
really is it's like performing eight
hours a day
are you trying to nudge me into becoming
a teacher there's no way
you'd be good at it actually um sit down
class i chuck a chicka chicka chicka i
actually
at ucb in la did a sketch for a not
sketch i wrote but i performed in it
a rapping teacher sketch where i
wrapped the history of world war ii for
this class and the whole point of the
sketch was just it was so embarrassing
that they
um actually did commit suicide that was
that that was the sketch
ah ucb blessing bless your wanted halls
it was a good sketch so that's a really
[ __ ] situation for everyone i don't
really know
how to go i mean yeah i don't there's
not an obvious solution i don't think
yeah you know because if i was a teacher
especially you know a lot a lot of these
teachers have
people who are vulnerable in their lives
the solution is vaccinate the teachers
well i think also that's not even the
solution because the vaccine doesn't
necessarily prevent you from spreading
it so if i'm a teacher
with we don't know that we do not have
evidence to suggest that it doesn't but
we shouldn't
then say that that means that it okay
all right fine but
i don't think i would feel comfortable
if say you had a lung problem
and i was a teacher yeah i would feel
deeply uncomfortable going back into
school
yeah no i agree because the fact is you
know teaching is really important
am i willing to potentially lose my
husband over it
i don't think so you're not committed
enough to teaching alice
you have to teach to the point that your
husband will perish
so that's our covered news news story
from brexit britain
brexit britain um under-loved fish
renamed for british tastes so fishermen
are going to rename
two of their like biggest they catch a
lot of fish that they don't
sell in britain because british people
don't like their names they can export
it to the continent
and the continent like yeah we'll eat
that but now exports are hardest they're
having to sell at home
so the two exports were a megrim soul
which obviously you're not gonna order
if that wasn't a menu would you like
some megrim show
spider crab mate now spider crabs look
minging but i've had spider crab and
it's
bomb diggity i love it so all of this
reminds me of like in world war ii i
can't remember the details but didn't
they like rename turnips like
freedom potatoes or something i think
you're thinking freedom fries from
french fries during the war on terror
because the french wouldn't help america
in iraq
and so you petty yank that was [ __ ]
ridiculous we didn't call them french
fries anymore we're gonna call them
freedom fries
right all right well anyway no but there
is a thing
there is a thing in in the wall with uh
rationing they were always renaming
things
uh to try and they did it's just it
feels quite um it just feels quite
wartime really so they've renamed them
megrim soul is now called cornish soul
and spider crab is cornish king crab
that does sound tastier than
spider crap and it was the head of the
cornish fish producers associate
fish producers that is some real
some real euphemistic names going there
they're fish catchers
they're fish murderers they're fish
slaughters fish producers the other way
they produce fish when they
hand it out to you yeah they're not
giving birth to the fish yeah exactly i
mean that would be absolutely horrible
all these cornish men just oh squeeze
out a bit of i can't do it with a
oh or a cornish maggot i don't think you
should try this i'm
doing it my sister lives in cornwall uh
she asked me if i'm gonna go do a show
there and i said it's five hours drive
do you know in uh medieval literature
there's this like
just continual references to all the
cornish
being cowards and so tristan is
a cornish knight and he's always coming
up against this where people will be
like
don't worry about tristan he's from
cornwall we'll take him easy
and then he's tristan and he [ __ ]
kills everyone but it's just a weird
thing because i don't think that's like
a that's not like a reputation that
cornish have
now but it really was back in the day
the reputation the cornish have is being
very specific about the order you put in
cream and jam
yeah that's their main thing isn't it
for americans a scone is like a sweet
biscuit for british ascon is a scone if
you pronounce it that way
i don't pronounce that i pronounce it's
scone cause otherwise the joke doesn't
work what's the fastest cake in the
english language
scone my favorite thing of this new
story was
paul trebel [ __ ] that's his name and
he's from the cornish fish producers
organization paul trebel [ __ ]
we say this again i'll say it travel
times paul
treble [ __ ] he's got three penises right
he said there's something about the
names as native connotations uh
exporting to europe in the current
climate is not a pleasant experience
what a way to understate brexit i bet
paul treble [ __ ] voted for brexit
i bet he did you're making a lot of
class assumptions i know because the
fishermen
the fishermen were mad about brexit we
want our waters back
fishing contributes 1.5 percent of
british gdp
fishermen are not the demographic either
they can [ __ ] off on their trolls
become abruptly anti-fishing yes yes
hey the only thing i fish for is
compliments
no a way out of watching titanic come on
it's so
good where's my phone the costumes
everything about that film is perfect
except for the script
while i unfreeze my phone alice is going
to tell you why titanic is good so the
thing is it is amazing
that so many excellent what a shame it's
unfrozen came together
to create the masterpiece of the 20th
century
and that is titanic yes the script is
bad yes the acting is amazing
the ship is huge okay so speaking about
icebergs
ice news ice news ice news
ice news there's a new section called
ice news great i look forward to it hey
guess what's happened in holland baby
oh everything's frozen over and
everyone's skating on the uh
yeah they reclaimed all that land from
the water but they love water what
i i know this because i have a friend
who lives in utrecht and
she sends me a lovely photograph so
utrecht was the first place in holland i
ever went to
and i went there on in 2009 january 2009
and it was the first time in many years
they told me that the canals had frozen
over
and the fun thing was everyone was
skating about in their grandparents
skates
and it turns out in the past everyone
had ice skates yeah and so they were
using all these things
and the thing my british health and
safety sensibilities were shocked
because
there was no supervision and we walked
down the canal
which i was terrified by i'm an absolute
absolute wimp
we are like a cornish man i i just i am
oh my god i'm full on all i do is
put cream on in the wrong order um i
firmly believe you should put cream then
jam the cornish do not agree with that
because they made this cornish clotted
cream they're like
that's our best export put it on
the cream is the butter and the jam is
the topping god i want skins
you don't you don't put cheese on the
top of you put your toppings on pizza
then cheese on top like an absolute nut
some lovely clotted cream uh we're
walking down the entrance canal and then
the ice just stopped and it was canal
and
there was a cone at the end of it well
we have to have some type of barrier to
show people where one cone should do yes
okay
hey don't walk down past the cone and uh
you never have that in britain you'd
absolutely have a bobby there going
oh no no no what's all this then don't
go any further and then they'd
batter you with a night stick and say
get back inside you're violating cobia
protocols
the terms used to freeze over they used
to have these ice creams in the 1800s
right
earlier as well tell us about charles
dickens baby uh i wasn't actually
thinking about i'm thinking of in
virginia woolf's orlando which is a
lovely book it's really really
interesting
um orlando set in florida it's about
so basically uh vita sackwell sackville
west
was virginia woolf's um that's what
girlfriend and
um she had she should have inherited
this massive mansion
but because she was a woman she couldn't
inherit it and so virginia woolf wrote
this book
about a young man in the 1500s who
inherits this just
utterly splendid manor house and the
descriptions of it are gorgeous
and he kind of just lives forever and um
then around the 1700s he gets sick and
when he wakes up he's a woman
um and you know everyone's everyone's
like well you are a woman but on the
other hand you used to be a man so i
guess we'll let you continue to have
rights
so then orlando man slash woman gets to
keep
this beautiful amount of house so who do
you think has the better deal is it
yeah in metamorphosis metamorphosis is
it better to wake up as a bug when you
were a man or better to wake up as a
woman when you're a man
it's funny you mentioned metamorphosis
because i think she got the idea from it
from of its metamorphosis
because in of it's this is not the
answer to what was it of its metaphor
well it's a bunch of different stories
and it one of the stories is about
tyresius who is a prophet
uh who in dante is condemned to always
look backwards because he tried to see
the future but in
ovid he um he briefly turns into a woman
for seven years
and i think apparently this was an
inspiration
uh would i rather turn into a woman or a
bug uh it's a difficult question
because you are a woman yeah so
therefore you've never had the
experience of a bug so wouldn't you like
to try out a bug
it would be curious think of of how much
you could sort of um fall from things
without hurting yourself
think of how much more i would love you
oh my god oh alice your carapace is so
shiny
legs got some news about your favorite
man
uh pope francis the pope i love pope
francis
pope baby i'm going to read this off
because this i i saw this and i just
didn't believe this was a thing
pope francis has launched a partnership
between the vatican and some of the
world's largest companies non-profits
and government agencies
to reform capitalism he's such a babe
he's taken on
he's such a dung communist pope
communist i
just love him um the council for
inclusive capitalism where the vatican
is led by the guardians for inclusive
capitalism
great name the guardians franklin god
it's the new marvel series
guardians for starring people such as
bank of america man
under the pope's guidance these
guardians aim to reform capitalism into
a powerful force for the good of
humanity
and create a more inclusive sustainable
and trusted form of capital literally
every time i hear
anything about pope francis it's because
he's done something just really nice
it's always him like like he like got a
bunch of parents
of gay children and like got them in a
room and was like
it's okay that your kids are gay stop
worrying about it that's nice
he he's just always you know he's just
when the catholic church is annoyed
about their choice of pope it's a good
pope right
that's a good point yeah one of my
favorite jokes i used to do was about
the
catholic sex abuse scandal and i'd uh
talk about and then say oh i know there
might be some catholics in the audience
saying no
no no our priests are innocent i go no
that was 13 of your popes
because there were 13 pope innocents
that they their name
innocent pope
i love it i love it yeah i actually do
like it what's the what's the
short for that scent
you know you know it was kind of nice
but it sounds like brian the problem
with it is that i suspect
a considerable number of those pope
innocents were nasty pieces of work
what the head of the catholic church
being a nasty piece of work
so pope francis is going to reform
kaepernick i just love him i just
just really like that he's around okay
by the way he's going on my list okay so
i have a list of people
that you can have sex with and not be
cheating on me alice he is celibate that
is a waste
you fool is yes best choice it's it's a
list of people where
if and when they die i believe i get
extra grief then like as an i i should
be the person
who gets all the sympathy and experience
yeah when mf doom died right anyone
posting about mf doom it wasn't me i was
like
well yeah you don't care as much right i
also was a bit shocked that
certain people who you know i was
grateful that people think of me but
there were some people who met me like
hey
hey bro you seen mf dooms died i was
like yes
stop reminding me of course i thought mf
doom has died it's my favorite
right i appreciate that people saying
that but it was like there was someone
like five days after was like oh you
know
if doom's dead like i'd forgotten about
it for a while
um yeah yeah i feel that way about
the pope i feel that way about john
williams listen i don't have i don't
have like
this is a record now you've never had
this as a record yeah i do want this on
the record okay so when john williams
when john williams dies this is what's
going to happen john williams those of
you that don't know is the composer who
did everything in the entire world the
most
oscar nominations of anyone ever more
than just disney
indiana jones he did harry potter he did
star wars he did so many things
point is when he dies everyone's going
to go on instagram
and post things like i really like john
williams because
i saw harry potter and it really i
really liked it so um i'm really sad
about jeremy's dying and that's fine
listen we all grew up
as an instagram caption it's a bit
waffling i'm just saying
i'm here first this is my instagram post
right
this is me saying i love john williams
he has crafted my life
when he dies please think of me yeah
lovely great you heard it here first
final part of the show breaking news
john williams has died so that's that's
pretty awkward
pretty awkward no breaking news it's not
death it's life
you know i mentioned archie mountbatten
windsor
absolutely he gonna be a little brother
well i'm sorry he gotta be a brother
he's gonna have the so meghan mark is
having a second child craig is now
that's interesting because it wasn't
part of
um the rule of the royal family is
you're only allowed one child
no that's not it at all in fact they've
never had that rule because they want an
errand aspect
about china yes but the point is uh i
remember there being a bit of
a ruckus because harry and megan said
they only wanted to have one child for
climate change reasons wow
well in that case this is not happy news
they are killing the planet we should
let's go and burn them down do we know
if it's a girl or a boy
um i don't know i don't think they've
said that yet they just released a photo
in black and white
of harry sat in the grass and megan
lying
on him uh and she's cradling her bump
well i wish them well i wish them well
too but they you know
it is really hot have you ever seen uh a
side-by-side comparison of the kate
middleton
articles and the meghan markle articles
i have yes it is so okay
by the way big kate middleton fan love
her hats i'm a fan i'm not pitting them
against each other but
you will you could see these articles
and it's literally like this is one i
actually saw
it was um a picture of kate middleton
with her hand over
a baby bump and the caption the headline
was something like you know
kate middleton loves babies because
she's a wonderful mother and a beautiful
princess
and then the headline for meghan markle
and it was a picture of meghan markle
holding
her belly uh in the exact same pose and
the
headline was why does meghan markle keep
groping her stomach is it a new age
california thing
or is it or is it insecurity about her
marriage and it was something
like that and it was bonkers it was so
strange and especially because if you
had the opportunity to grow up meghan
markle's stomach
you would chris especially if she's
pregnant uh
he's such a weirdo so um let's just
expand on that
i think pregnant women are the hottest
type of women i've spoken about this
before
probably in a freestyle rap on stage
when it was like why has he stopped
rhyming
and he's just furiously wanking it is
not
talking about pregnancy it is a sort of
less
more information than i wanted to know
about you
um let alone that's why i put in the
brain i just wanted an excuse to look at
the photo again
well anyway i i sympathize um with
meghan markle uh and i hope her
pregnancy goes well
yes i hope it does too the second one
more likely or less likely for morning
sickness
i don't know the answer to that how
you're rubbing why would you assume i
would know the answer to that
just because i'm a lady because you're a
woman not a bug or are you a bug alice
alice actually is a bug
because last night she bloody plastered
her face in snail
um yes i have i have invested in a new
skincare routine um
cream that is 96
snail mucus now i know in this podcast
we've already spoken about how alice has
some dead animals that she hangs around
her neck and you're not thinking
wow this is even crueler she milked
snails to get their juices
actually okay i actually i asked my
friend about this
i asked i was my friend was like i use
this skin cream it's really good
and i was like do they hurt the snails
and she said
if the snails are stressed the mucus
loses its skin care properties which is
how you know it's [ __ ] it's how you
know it's
absolutely no because they secrete like
a stress thing and so the snails have to
be like
pampered into releasing their mucus the
kobe beef
of skin care you have to massage the
cows give them
beer and then so with cows if you with
any animal if you
if it's stressed before they didn't kill
it then it's meat becomes tougher
because it releases the stress hormone
is what the meat industry say and i am
skeptical of it
because well they would just say that to
make us think that they have a nice time
listen i would bathe in the blood of a
child if it will keep me beautiful for
longer so
all right countess first bit by three
she was probably wronged by the way the
people who spread those rumors about her
bathing in the blood of virgins
wanted her land bathory erzbet one of
the
best songs on the sun album black one
do go listen to that if you like music
that can't really be classified as
music um we've come to the
end of the news which means we've come
to the start
of alice's news i'm sorry is that really
all the news that's happening
all the news has happened every week i
think you make this joke no i'm not
making a joke i'm just sort of supplied
by the end of the news i mean there is
no more news ever this is our final
episode
let me explain my my perpetual surprise
which is that
people seem to spend a limitless amount
of time
reading the news i yeah because there's
loads of stories i mean there's plenty
of stories there was a very funny match
at the australian tennis open where um
the player was up by two two sets
and then he lost the next two shouted
abuse at everyone in four different
languages
turned to his coach and was like this is
your fault so his coach
packed up and left uh and afterwards was
like well if he's just gonna be like
that i thought it was best that i wasn't
there
and then the guy actually won and
thanked the coach being like that was
the right thing to do thank you for
leaving i was just really
losing it that was a news story um
there's plenty of news stories i just
pick out the ones that i think you need
to know about i don't think you need to
know about
australian tennis even though it would
be bloody good australia news might
i think i suppose this is the problem
with me only getting my news
fully biased uh yeah it's 100 i mean i
don't only get my news from you right i
deal with
just various people drop it in don't
they but um
various people me and instagram that's
where you get your news from
i mean i hope that people who listen to
this and i hope you enjoy it i hope you
don't only get your news from me
i don't know that seems to be working
out all right for me yeah
yeah i mean because the thing is if it
was just from me all you would know
about this week is what he's talking
about and the fact that there are still
elk outside our window there
are yeah they're really yeah just elking
about
oh i used to used to date a girl called
elka
i actually i remember you telling me she
was pretty said very pretty yeah
i only date pretty women how dare you
everyone i've dated is absolutely
stunning
um so uh it's time for alice's news
alice who are you going to tell us about
this week i thought i'd tell you about
charles baudelaire
um he kind of ties in with edgar allan
poe who i talked about last week
um so baudelaire very famous french poet
um while we wait i'll tell you guys
about why titanic is
a bad movie so it's far too long and
yeah look james cameron is a very adept
director it's not too long he's also
right
aliens aliens is a brilliant film so
it's titanic
no it's not a brilliant i think if you
watch it again you're gonna see that
like gladiator it is one of the finest
films one of the main draws of titanic
four people is leonardo dicaprio is fit
in it right
that's a that's small fry what it's the
costumes it's the music it's the pathos
it's the hubris of empire
ah never watching that film the ship is
unsinkable i will turn you into a bug
okay so charles berliner is born i think
in the nine
uh yeah 1820s roughly uh in paris
and um the main love of his life was his
mother
uh so his father died when he was about
five and then his mother didn't remarry
until he was ten and for those five
glorious years it was just baudelaire
and his mother and he
loved it sounds like a healthy
relationship then his mother
uh remarried this quite glamorous sort
of diplomat type
and baudelaire was sent off to boarding
school and
uh he never really got over the mother's
remarriage it really upset him
and in boarding school he was um i think
he was quite cool he was like
very very literary and everyone was sort
of very um
it shows how different the times were
isn't it because people like that now
get put in a bloody bin
no i'm telling you i think he would have
done fine anywhere i'd like to apologize
for the
the person at my secondary school who i
did put in did you really put someone in
a bin with your billy
was quite a bullying that's horrid i
know not that much of a bully but
well i think you you probably were in
the position where you had to bully or
be
bullied yes that was very true because i
was tall i was sick for a while but i
was also
a glasses-wearing nerd yeah so it was
like look use your height your advantage
and bully the heck out of something
right or get it turned on yourself
and so you just you gotta yeah you've
got to put stamp your authority on it
really early on
bully them like you know i was bullied
in primary school
and i asked someone i was like what do i
do and they went just hit one of them
really hard and i was like what but then
all the rest you went no
get them on their own and so on one day
when
when all the bullies because their
bullies were in the year above me
um when all the all the people in the
air above me were on a school trip
one of them one of the bullies hadn't
had his parents signed a permission
i mean in retrospect yes all those
people who bullied me
were i pretty sure very troubled
um and i was probably the dick right
well
i think i teased them a lot right b i
was all going yeah what you gonna do
absolutely
yeah no i i have faith in the idea that
you were probably in the wrong in all of
these interactions
um and so yeah i just got on his own and
i went never bullying me again he was
like what are you gonna do and i punched
him really hard and he went okay i'll
never believe again
it worked guys i i too was bullied
um quite a bit but i do think i was
asking for it
so whenever i say that to people
they're always horrified but i don't
think they realize just how strange i
was the thing is you know you were
bullied by people putting like snails in
your hair and what you've realized since
is they were just trying to help you
with a skincare i wouldn't put snails in
my hair
but um i did want to have a boyfriend
bring me a snail as a gift
anyway it was a dead snail it wasn't
it's kind of weird to expose our
relationship
what we did this valentine's day on this
podcast right now okay it was a dead
snail but it's cold here
so beau de la um when he was like 15 16
he
he left the boarding school that was out
of paris and went
to go carry on his schooling in paris
and he went a bit off the rails um
he started gambling he started using
uh sex workers and i guess visiting sex
workers at the age of 15 and 16.
yes he contracted syphilis and maybe
even gonorrhea i think he might be the
frenchest person i've ever
heard of he um he also started spending
a lot of money on clothes
and he dressed so well and he was like a
real dandy about town
and then um when he was in his like
maybe we i think he must have been about
20 he inherited some money
and um spent all of it within about two
years
uh like so much money was spent um
and his stepfather was worried about him
and tried to get him straight
sort of on the straight and narrow by uh
sending him away to calcutta
but the ship sank off the coast of
mauritius
uh and we don't really have much
information about the shipwrecks had
probably given it syphilis
he um yeah so he ended up coming back to
paris but the uh the
you know the sea voyage um why is
sending to calcutta a way to get you on
the straight and narrow
i don't think that it i don't think
calcutta was like
the place to go i just think he thought
if he got him out of paris
okay um to another exotic land
yeah i do think bed like could have
gotten into trouble anywhere but
the problem is right whenever i hear
calcutta or kolkata
all i think about is pandemic legacy
season one and it just brings great
dread to me i'm like oh no that region's
just collapsing over and
[ __ ] over that whole part of the board
yeah sorry middle east
sorry subcontinent it was um yeah so he
comes back
as i said this voyage had a pretty big
impact on a lot of his poetry he's one
of his most famous poems is called
albertos and it is a poem comparing the
plight of being a poet among ordinary
people
to the plight of being an albatross how
an albatross in
in the wind you know flies and is a
prince of nature greatest wings
but when you bring the albatross down
when the sailors tear him down you know
he becomes this like
you know this um limping creature who
becomes sort of
pathetic and and uh powerless among the
sailors
so the idea is that a poet in his poetry
has wings but
in real life is miserable and um he
comes back
from this um he carries on spending lots
of money he starts dating this very
beautiful mixed-race haitian actress
called
jean-juven who was also painted by manet
very different two whole vowels
different
and uh it's one vowel two whole vowels
two move two along
oh i see um and she went blind from
syphilis and died eventually so he
blinded her he gave her it
not clear how she got to there's not
really a good way of knowing how either
of them got syphilis what happens when
you've got syphilis for those
listeners who've never had syphilis so
syphilis is an interesting one uh you
know
mostly europe europe benefited from um
what's known as the colombian exchange
which is where
we in the 14 14 15 1600s got a lot of
cocaine
we in europe got potatoes and tomatoes
and various other things and um
you know took over all the land and
stole their silver and um destroy their
culture
and uh they
also we picked up along the way syphilis
syphilis comes over in this time period
and syphilis is a pretty nasty
disease a sexually transmitted disease
um i
i i believe it makes you go mad
although that might be in part because
they believed that one of the
cures for syphilis was mercury baths so
sort of hard to distinguish between the
treatments and
the disease in terms of what it did but
uh all sorts of
all sorts of things that it does to you
i i don't really know the details but
it's
it makes you lose your nose uh it can
make bits of your body fall off
um yeah so lord rochester in the 1600s
his nose fell off
it should be pointed out people think
you know people often say tycho brahe
the famous italian astronomer i don't
remember where he's from
um mediterranean astronomer guy tycho
brahe
uh was missing his nose and had a fake
bronze or gold nose
uh but he actually lost that in a jewel
uh so it wasn't syphilis
and he still never knows he died because
he was too polite to go to the loo at a
dinner party yeah his bladder exploded
they got an infection
which also happened about 12 years ago
when a radio station held a hold your
wii
for a wii contest and they asked people
to drink water and a woman's bladder
exploded and she died because she wanted
a nintendo wii that's so sad it's really
sad
that's a hard way to die um they did
give a family a nintendo wii though
i don't think that that joke is
appropriate so um
yes so he got civilized she has syphilis
everyone has syphilis
um and to be honest in this time period
he seems like he's having a great time
he he joined a club
called lee hashashan i think which was
basically
a hashish club wait do you know about
this club well the hashishians
is a central part of the mythology and
law
of the sleep song slash album dope
smoker
okay and what do they say about it are a
group of people
crossing the deserts uh to go to
nazareth
uh yeah
this is different from that it's i mean
that's an hour-long song written by
three guys who were given a quarter of a
million pounds to spend on guitars
amplifiers and marijuana
recorded truly hate if you have any
interest in heavy music
dope smoker by sleep is one of the best
best piece of music i've put
um so uh the the hershey's
were basically run by a doctor who
wanted to see
like what the effect of various drugs
were i think on art
so he just it was a really cool sounding
club in a way
um you know not as good as the lost
cause mate best club of all time stop
this
so you had um uh i don't know how to say
it in english still feel good here
and victor hugo and alexandre dumas
and um de la croix the painter
uh and flo bear briefly and i mean these
are all like some of the greatest
french artists in this time period
french writers front artists and
baudelaire
and they're all in this club where um i
think it's sort of charming
they're mainly just smoking weed and
they're all being like this is crazy
stuff man
um but they did also do opium
and uh yes let's get more opium in since
last week had so many messages about
people saying where can i try some opium
have you actually it sounds really cool
i don't want to i don't want to
encourage people we have not do not
take opium i don't think it makes
people's lives nicer
so look pretty fine to me people play
the violin excellently
so baudelaire uh starts taking laudanum
which is an opiate
um to to deal with some of his
syphilitic symptoms
and becomes very addicted and uh in this
time period he's having a really rough
go of it um he misses his mum
all the time he doesn't he's always
poor uh he can't finish any projects but
he does
translate all of edgar allan poe's works
and
um that's well all of his stories anyway
um and they're
these beautiful french translations
about grell and poe and
um then in his 30s he
releases his most famous and enduring
work which is a book of poetry called
le fleur dumel which means the flowers
of evil he had started working on these
poems when he was in his early 20s
uh but the the problem is of course
these poems are incredibly um offensive
to flowers morals of the time and so he
was
fined 300 francs he was forced to remove
three poems from
the uh edition do we have the three
poems yes we do and isolation
i haven't looked at them um but the one
like the ones i have looked at so he's
got he's got perms about lesbianism
he's got times about sex he's got poems
about drugs he's got
the poem i just read about that he wrote
was
literally a praise satan poem
which is like not on in the 1850s you
can't just
go around praising satan anton levay in
the church of satan was in the 1960s in
in america that's
he's a real trailblazer um i think you
know
he's he it all kind of ties in
with um his sort of philosophy on life
uh oh i forgot to tell you this anecdote
about him which is that at one point um
there were rumors flying around paris
that he was gay and
um when these rumors reached him his
friends were like by the way are you
worried about the fact that everyone's
saying you're gay
and he was like ha ha i started that
rumor
so i was mentioning this anecdote um to
my parents and my father was like well
of course with rambo
and i was like ah actually that checks
out because sylvester
stallone wasn't even alive rambo is a
famous french poet who i believe wrote
most of his poetry when he was 17
and then had like some kind of psychotic
breakdown when he looked in a mirror and
never wrote again
so um i think that's the deal with rambo
but i'd have to check up
anyway the the thing that's interesting
to me about berlin um oh he died oh it
was actually quite horrible he
he got a he got a stroke that um in his
40 early 40s i think he had a stroke
which um
prevented him from having the capacity
to translate his thoughts into words
um which is horrid so he still had the
thoughts but he could not use
words uh and that lasted for a year and
then he died
that sucks yeah wow um i can't even put
that into words
oh no um and
what's interesting is that he he's
writing you know the fiji model i think
comes out in the 1850s
uh but he has a huge influence on the
the decadence movement do you know what
the decadence movement is the economics
movement is a founder ciacular movement
so it's a movement um in the 1880s and
90s sanders yackler translates as end of
the century
correct and uh it's a it's a movement
where uh it's kind of the
sex drugs and rock and roll of the 1890s
and uh
um anyway yeah but so oscar wilde's um
dorian gray fits into the decadence
movement you know the cut the cartoons
and drawings of um aubry bearsley
uh and a lot of these artists look back
at um baudelaire and they thought you
know
that he really exemplified decadence and
decadence is
the idea that you should look at
darkness and its sin and at
things that are unnatural not at things
that are natural it's sort of like a
like a negative like the negative of
romanticism
in a way uh it's it's all about the sort
of seedy underbellies of cities and it's
all about sexual experimentation and
drug use and trying to
undermine nature and there is beauty in
the urban
uh and so yeah his poems you know are
pretty groundbreaking and they
really deal with a lot of those decadent
themes
thank you very much i feel like we've
learned a lot there it's also made me
think of a new joke
my dog has no nose he's got syphilis
it is the end of the show properly now
the elk is still there they've hung
around for the whole recording so thank
you very much i hope you've hung around
the end of recording not just because
there is a
wrap but because you've enjoyed it if
you have enjoyed it then please do give
it a rating a review on the apple
podcasts app
share it with a friend that you think
might like it spread it around
and we do appreciate that and let's do a
bloody
freestyle rap about the week's news on
last week's episode we
we wrapped uh with you throwing the
stresses out during the beat people seem
to like that thank you for those
comments do
leave a comment on things that you find
interesting it always helps us know
which way to get the episodes but the
beat's about to drop do you have any
suggestions
yes okay cool free britney is one second
okay this beats too
loud it's too loud there we go
we got it i heard it i heard it
decibels swell like the sound it be
hitting me got a free everything
especially the brittany it's a big
mistake when the timberlake snake came
on the radio
and he's always trying to take the piss
and then a dad
jamie spears coming on and taking
everything and leave her in her ears
that being dead
it's kind of weird that i'm gonna say
that she made a million dollars every
week in vegas
gotta rename it it's all going wrong
king crab from cornwall comes strong
with
a rebranding not the spider crab cause
that sounds so horrible not signing that
on the menu never order it with the cash
if i get a spider crab i'll be sending
right back
gotta rebrand that yeah it might annoy
you if you got a filter on me like a
tiny kitten lawyer tom sawyer tells a
story in this guy from the south
but why's he got the whiskers on the
sides of his mouth with a little tongue
with the tiny papillae
that's the little hooks that they call
hey the
if you're in massachusetts gather round
you'll get an old lady put her in a
wheelchair you can jump ahead in the
line you can steal their place if you
pretend
that you're a caregiver be aware of your
liver you might feel all of the shivers
that's the side effects
if it's not your turn next bad calm so i
don't get that respect oh yeah
archie was an only child but then harry
and megan they got it wet and so wild
got impregnated and in a few
months we won't be able to see megan's
baby bump but for now
it's a good thing looking nice getting
that baby swell the pain with eyes put
it on to take away
ice like the dutch if you're on a frozen
lake you can touch it with your little
finger stick it like your tongue the
connection between the water molecules
is strong so you can't rip an eye like a
finger in the dyke
dutch on ice that's the thing that they
like you can within your reach red light
district impeach a little trump cause
the guy's a dick
all the republicans except seven of them
were like now unconstitutional get him
off then
he can lead the party m-a-g-a democrats
don't live to fight another day
impeach that peach [ __ ] one more
time
for committing all those crimes maybe
two more things we can fit in
topic for which to spit in doesn't even
matter
yeah she don't care your dad was
chilling right there upon the chair
maybe reading over there but he didn't
feel good then he didn't realize the
needle wasn't his foot he just thought
that's a bone spur definitely
so he came and told us during chinese
feast new year tea
saying my feet's too hurty all of your
family were like oh we care see
mr david go and take the ibuprofen pope
francis
our hearts will be broken if he dies
alice will cry all of the tears but
pope francis saves the day he's here
everybody give a cheer
church had a schism catholic and
prostitute but he kills capitalism
boom what a great beat it's a great
it's a really good visa mate if you like
that beat you'll be pleased to know that
i um
did a live show this week for just the
tonic at the leicester comedy festival
and i did two two three stars yeah i
didn't go to leicester
even if covered wasn't happening i
wouldn't go to leicester i'm joking i
love lester i've been there several
times
it's really nice and fast improving city
sound like lester's got a gun to your
head mate
i mean if you go to leicester they
probably do um so i i did a show
and i used that beef one of my
freestyles and we did record it and that
beat will be on youtube that freestyle
will be on the youtube channel in a
couple of weeks when i'm allowed to
when the embargo is lifted from that
footage and i can share it out
what's going on in leicester there's
embargo lester comey festival's still on
so you can't share stuff from it until
then we did a great job giving out
suggestions
i've just realized i did miss a good
opportunity for the the joke of when
they were ice skating
um you know those canals were it was
ramp pack because it was the first time
in age they've been able to ask it was
just jammed full they were just so
you could say those canals were
completely clogged hey
and with that brilliant joke it's the
best show you're gonna hear all week and
it's only a monday if you listen to this
when we put it out
uh you might be listening to this a
little bit later than usual because it's
valentine's day so i think we're gonna
go and have
a meal and watch a movie rather than me
edit this straight away but it should be
up
at some point uh midday valentine's i
hope you've enjoyed listening
you can check alice out let them eat
books with understanding
that way can't check her out properly
because she's married right uh
i think you'll find that a woman's
sexuality is not bound to her marital
status
shut up bug no she has got much more
attractiveness and she started putting
snail glue on her face
i didn't think it was possible i was
like she's the most beautiful thing in
the world and then she was like and now
dripping with slime
so yeah let them eat books under schools
instead of spaces you can follow me
chris turner comedy
on the instagram and you can find me on
youtube just search chris turner and
i'll i'll come up
um thank you for listening it's been
lovely
goodbye the elk had gone